Okay.
I'm gonna fly.
Yeah.
You got to force it to come out.
What do you want?
You're a genius.
I know what I say. No!
Did you know what was going to happen
to my brother
when you stuck him with this world
destroying thing?
It's called the Scarab.
I had no idea it would activate.
It has to choose you.
So how do we get it to our anxiously
host acquired
Who said that? Systems tracking three
Host Overreacting. Overreacting.
I'll go check,
but I'm done with that, you know?
You know,
so that a person in drinking post
protection
threat eliminated.
Sorry about that
I got it out, but what do you think
the government is going to do
when they figure out that
some kid has some military tech?
We're going to change the world
with the power of the scarab.
It belongs to me.
Oh, he's pissed
Listen to me!
you got the wrong guy.
I'm a nobody.
I swear.
The world is a place to protect.
I have an arsenal at my disposal.
Anything.
Please watch and learn jaime
Whatever you can imagine,
I can create.
That's more like it.
That love
yo feel for your family makes you weak
You're wrong.
My family, that's what makes me strong.
Oh, my.
Oh, I forgot how bad it looks.
Target the family.
Sorry.
me mom
Jaime?
You're the blue beetle that could use that
arsenal right about now.
Thought you'd never ask. Oh, yeah.
I advise we back away.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
They just dropped a brand new blue
Beetle trailer with a whole bunch
new footage, so we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
here for a bunch of different DC things.
James Gunn was also talking
about the future of the character
inside his new DC studios.
The new DC Chapter one as well.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They'll be a bunch of big announcements
and a bunch of more trailers
coming in the next couple of weeks because
the movie is coming out next month.
And James
Gunn has basically just been dropping
all the details about Superman Legacy
recently to even just announced
what a lot of the new version
of the Justice League is going to be,
which will be in Superman legacy,
like a bunch of the new Justice
League characters will be in that movie.
I'll do a completely separate video
about that the next couple of days.
Just because there's so much stuff
that he released.
Like, for instance, Nathan Fillion is now
playing Guy Gardner Green Lantern.
That's right.
Nathan Fillion, Green Lantern,
Finally so fast on the towel.
You'll have to do better than that.
We should do.
Darkseid is more powerful. Dark.
Not so fast. Dark.
Looks like we got here in the nick of time
and we got backup.
Let's lock
per the announcement,
Blue Beetle will be a big part of that.
And even though the people that
made Blue Beetle say that they want there
to be a trilogy of Blue Beetle movies,
I don't know that they're going to do Blue
Beetle too.
a lot of that just depends on the box
office.
Now, they didn't spend nearly as much
money as they did on the Flash movie,
so it doesn't have to make nearly
as much as the Flash, like
the Flash would have had to made
about $1,000,000,000
in order to make it into profit.
No way That's going to happen now.
But if Blue Beetle does well enough,
then they might do the second movie.
during the new trailer,
you see a bunch more of car
parks and Victoria Court
played by Susan Sarandon,
who are basically
the villains of this movie.
The Reach is technically the real bill are
the people
that actually built the scarabs.
but I think they just barely get into them
during this movie.
They explain a little bit
about where the scarabs come from,
but not completely get into that.
there are a lot of other DC
Easter eggs and references,
like they made the Batman jokes
in the first trailer
and there are references
to some of the other characters
like in this
you see Ace Chemical in the background
from the Batman comics, you see Lex Corp.
So there are ties to a lot of the other
big Superman Batman, other huge characters
but they themselves
like Superman isn't actually in this movie
part of the reason
why it's able to survive the transition
into James Gunn's new DCU,
it would have actually gone worse for them
if Ben Affleck's
Batman and Henry CAVILL'S
Superman actually showed up in this movie,
it would've been harder to explain him
showing up in the New DC movies.
is certainly the beginning of the trailer
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments.
The trailer itself
is a little out of order, But.
They start with a funny scene of him
trying to activate the scarab on command,
trying
to figure out how to actually do it.
And he has to threaten his own life like,
Oh, I got it.
I'll just try to jump off the building
and pretend like I'm going to kill myself.
Then the scarab
will automatically activate.
And if it wasn't clear,
the voice of the scarab is
Becky G, who was part of the Power Rangers
back in the day.
She also just had a track on Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
to there's a little bit of power Rangers
action going on in this.
but part of the idea with the Blue
Beetle Scarab is that it was damaged
when it fell to earth.
So it doesn't listen to all the commands
like it doesn't obey
all the commands that the reach gives it.
Like the normal scarabs.
What, for instance,
the black beetle scarab,
Sometimes it'll do what high may
Raya's tells it to do.
And sometimes it'll do
what it wants to do.
Like the scarab has a will of its own.
think of it as, like, a really beefed up,
way, more advanced version of Iron
Man's Air Friday or Jarvis.
Like they're a couple of lines of dialog
where it sounds like the scarab actually
has its own sense of humor.
Like finally, let's have some fun.
this is is love interest Jenny.
She works for Cort Industries and steals
the scarab, giving it to him inadvertently
causing the scarab to bond with them,
not knowing that that was going to happen.
there isn't a Jenny from the comics.
So I think that
she might be an original character
they just introduced for the movie.
she's also the person that helps them get
into Ted Cord's lab later in the movie.
George Lopez is playing his uncle.
During the movie, his father is dead.
They do deal with the death of his father,
but it's kind of the same way
in the comics, too.
there might be a couple of flashbacks
to explain his father's death.
Or they'll just talk about it
a little bit.
this is inside the Cord Industries lab.
when she says
the scarab has to choose you.
The whole idea is that the rays conquer
different planets by sending a scarab
pretending like it's a good thing,
like a benevolent thing.
It'll find a compatible person
to bond with whose consciousness it can
then override and the reach will give it
commands, telling it
to take over a planet after a certain
level of technology has been reached.
So the whole idea is that the Blue Beetle
Scarab landed on Earth
about a thousand years ago.
Eventually, Dan Garrett found it couldn't
activate it couldn't bond with it.
Ted Cord
also found it, couldn't bond with it
but because Jaime Reyes
wound up being compatible with it.
That's
when the scarab finally fully activated.
when he asked them
how do we get the scared to untie
choose me the joke about that
is that you do not get to choose
you like he is the blue beetle
for the rest of his life.
hopefully it will be a long life.
all the dialog that you get from the suit
like host overreacting.
Please give me commands.
Tell me what to do.
Like asking for permission
to do certain things.
That's just it.
Trying to exert
its will under normal circumstances,
if the scarab hadn't been damaged,
it wouldn't need to do that.
The scarab would just do with the reach
it programed it to do
They'll probably use this for some WTF
reaction in the movie where he's not able
to get the scared to activate
or do things during critical points.
part of the idea is that it
doesn't always do what he asked it to do,
this is the car parks bill.
And without his suit
activated at this party,
you notice,
he has a couple different versions
of his suit
through the film, like he fights him
with a lesser version of his suit.
It seems like his suit.
Then bonds with cord tech.
The Victoria cord was messing
with this based on the scarab
so his suit was already core
tech derived from the scarab
but then it bonds
with this other scarab tech in
it winds up evolving into the much crazier
looking version of the suit
Later in the movie
so the movie is kind of using him
like a dark version of him a ray is like
he has a suit to kind of like
his only his isn't nearly as powerful
as the blue beetle suit
We see more of Victoria Court played
by Susan Sarandon along with Harvey Green.
From what we do in the Shadows,
who's playing Dr.
Sanchez, who's sort of like a misguided
scientist, is not totally evil enough
to make a Superman
Christopher Reeve reference
this scene of the three of them
at this Arctic base
feels very much out of the Superman
Christopher Reeve movies.
he be like a much smarter version of Otis
in this equation.
someone who isn't totally bad
but has been doing whatever
the villain Victoria Court in this case
has been telling him
to do up to a certain point.
So maybe he will wind up helping him
areas later in the film.
but it looks like this
Arctic base is where they're experimenting
with a lot of scarab tech.
this is probably when they'll start
to tease the connection to the reach.
the joke in the trailer I may
raise is a superhero,
whether he wants to be or not,
whether he likes it or not,
is the idea that the scarab will override
his personality if he's not careful,
like the suit will force him
to do what the reach wants him to do.
But the idea with Blue Beetle is that
the blue beetle scarab was damaged.
So it doesn't always do
what the reach wants it to do.
the other big part of the trailer here is
that they hype up the rest of his family
working with him.
Like you see George Lopez's uncle flying
the blue beetle.
Ted courtship,
that's also right out of the comics, too.
to make a DC in a marvel reference.
He's kind of like Ray Palmer,
the Atom who uses a lot of tech
to be a superhero
as well as Iron Man in the Marvel movies,
he uses a lot of his money
in tech to become a superhero.
I'm hoping is that Ted Kord is still alive
in the DC Universe and he just missing
People don't know where he is,
so they think that he's dead.
The history of his relationship
with Hymie Reyez blew.
Beetle is a little complicated.
They tried to sew that up a little bit,
and after a couple of DC reboots,
the comics basically brought them
both back at the same time.
so in the more modern
comics, TED Cause Blue Beetle winds up
being a mentor to him eventually.
but one of the other funny things in tying
this back to James Gunn's new DCU
is that peacemaker also winds up
being sort of a mentor to him.
A ray is blue beetle.
They've also been reports
that he might come back in cameo
in the new Booster Gold series
that DC is working on as well too.
that'll be part of James Gunn's new DCU.
They didn't say when the Booster
Gold Series will happen,
but eventually the next couple of years
they started to get into those characters
during the Smallville era.
So easy to imagine a much better
looking version of that.
His uncle calls
him Blue Beetle for the first time.
But the idea is that Ted
Kord was a version of the Blue
Beetle before that, so was dangerous.
So I don't know how they're going
to explain the origin of the actual name.
The Blue Beetle.
Maybe they'll find records of it
in Ted Cord's lab
and they'll just start calling him
that eventually.
Like you're the new blue Beetle.
Then they have the funny scene
when they're in Ted Cord's lab
with his grandma Meemaw, just picking up
some of TED cords, weapons
unleashing on all the guards.
suddenly the movie's testing really high
with Grandma's
there's a whole bunch of new footage here.
So if you spotted any new Easter eggs
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below in the comments.
in once the movie comes out,
I think the James Gunn girls are talking
more about the future of the character,
but I think a little bit of that depends
on how the movie does
financially at the box office.
Like do they do Blue Beetle too,
or does he just show up when they do
the Booster Gold Series?
Either way, the movie does feel like it's
going to be a solid small flick,
but it'll be much smaller in scope
than, say, like the Flash movie,
which was trying to be way bigger,
like a mini Justice League movie.
They did say
there would be a bunch of Blue
Beetle specific cameos,
but I think they were talking
about characters
from the Blue Beetle Comics.
Not necessarily like Big Justice League
crossovers or anything like that.
there was a bunch of other big stuff
that just released.
There was like a brand new Deadpool
3 teaser of Wolverine vs Deadpool
and a bunch of videos from the set.
So I'll do a video for that
in the next day or two.
click here for that new Deadpool
3 video.
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for my full secret invasion
Episode 4 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!